Musik Herzlich Willkommen. Lass mich noch mal ganz kurz in mein Gagblatt gucken. Ich brauche ein bisschen Vorbereitung. Du bist immer so ein Typ, du willst direkt aus der Tür raus springen. Du bist auch jemand, der steht... Ach Gott, das ist auch ein Problem. Wenn man anfängt mit, du bist auch jemand der, und dann fällt einem einfach nichts weiter ein. Lass mich noch ganz kurz mit mir den Gag. Herzlich Will willkommen zum Podcast UFO. Mein Name ist Stefan Tietze, neben mir sitzt Florentin Will und zusammen wollen wir heute die Folge 11 schon, ist es, bestreiten. Wir sind alle aufgeregt, es ist für uns alle das elfte Mal. Ab wann muss man eigentlich professionell werden? Gute Frage, ja. Das frage ich mich immer. Also ich glaube, man kann sich die ersten 100 Folgen noch damit rausreden, dass man ja gerade erst anfängt. Unser Thema ist heute technisch. Warte mal ganz kurz. Unser Thema ist heute Warte mal ganz kurz. Wenn ich sage, unser Thema, dann kannst du nicht sagen, dann kannst du nicht sagen, warte mal ganz kurz, weil dann ist die ganze Ammoderation völlig im Arsch. Ich weiß, wir müssen gleich nochmal anfangen. Oh, fick dich doch einfach mal! Das war der beste Anfang der Welt! Okay, nochmal, jetzt. Bist du genervt, Stefan? Hallo, mein Name ist Stefan und ich habe echt keinen Bock mehr, mit dem aufzunehmen. Warum denn nicht? Neben mir ist es Florentin Will. Wir haben Erfolg. Und das Will steht für Professionalität. Dankeschön, mein Name ist Stefan Titzel und wir hören uns heute mal die erste Folge des Podcast-Ufos an, wie das gelaufen ist, denn wir sind bei Folge 11, damit sind wir schon im 20.
Veto.
Ich bin da immer so ein bisschen verwirrt, mit dem ist ja auch so, ab 1901 ist man im 20. Jahrhundert, das heißt wir sind jetzt in den 20er Jahren.
Ja, ist aber auch nicht so schwer.
Ja, ist es eine humoristische Sicht auf die Welt, da muss man Dinge auch mal ein bisschen komplizierter nehmen, als sie tatsächlich sind, ja, verstehst du?
Heute ist nämlich das Thema Professionalität. Professionalität und Technik, das sind unsere zwei Themen.
Und Florentin hat nämlich heute technische Probleme und ich frage mich, warum.
Und er wird das sicherlich auch sagen, es ist nämlich so, dass wir jede Woche aufnehmen am gleichen Ort, zur selben Zeit, am selben Tag und meistens sogar mit der gleichen Einstellung. Und es ist halt so, dass Florentin komischerweise jede Woche wieder mit neuen Problemen ankommt und man weiß nicht warum. Naja, mit der gleichen Einstellung würde ich jetzt gar nicht sagen. Ich sehe da schon große Differenzen zwischen unseren beiden Einstellungen. Stefan Tütze kommt hier an, hat hier seinen Latte Macchiato in der Hand, hat sich wieder drei Seiten Gags von der Gag-Flatrate ausgedruckt, schlendert hier ins Studio, ja, hier wirft hier noch ein paar lustige Sprüche in die Ecke, die Grafiker versuchen zu arbeiten. Gibt den Praktikantin so einen Klops auf den Arsch. Genau, ja, die Grafiker versuchen zu arbeiten, du versuchst irgendwie, hey, hat jemand Lust mit mir Darts zu spielen und so, ne, so kommen Stefan Tütze hier rein. Ich habe auch so einen Golf-Teppich, den rolle ich manchmal aus, aber auch manchmal bei wichtigen Unterlagen, halt auf dem Tisch rolle ich dann meinen Golf-Teppich aus und versuche dann da einzulochen. Naja, kommt mich so gut an, kommt mich so gut an. Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich schnitt zu mir, ich sitze mit einer Stirnlampe in einem Kohlewerk, ich arbeite, hole die Kabel raus, schneit auf, guckt, sind die Kabel nicht ein bisschen verdreckt, bleibt da nicht ein bisschen Qualität hängen, kann man nicht noch ein bisschen mehr rausholen?
Du kommst von unten, du bist ein kleiner Mann. Ja, ich habe hochgearbeitet, ich kenne die Qualität, nur der, der unten arbeitet, der kann wirklich mit der Qualität was anfangen, weil der muss sich da dadurch, das ist meine Leiter sozusagen.
Und ich habe mir heute überlegt, wie geil werden denn mal Soundeffekte, mal so ein bisschen ein paar Sachen einspielen können, ein paar Jingle, ich habe extra ein paar Jingle gemacht, damit wir, wenn wir wieder Stefan Titzes, was war deine Scheiß, deine Rubrik, die du dir ausgedacht hast? Fische. Ja, Fische, dass man die halt irgendwie anmoderieren kann und sagen, jetzt kommen die Fische und dann blub, blub, blub, blub, blub. War eine gute Idee. War eine gute Idee, kann man sagen. Fische istes Comedy-Potential. Ja, aber vor allem die Flossen. Vor allem die Flossen und die Gesichter. Diese müden Gesichter, die manche gucken treu doof, manche gucken glücklich, immer glücklich, auch wenn sie total angepistet sind oder kurz vorm Verrecken sind, weil man die nicht füttert. Die haben halt immer den gleichen Gesichtsausdruck. Ich will gleich mal die Stimmung runterziehen. Fische sind auch wahnsinnig schlechte Schauspieler wahrscheinlich deswegen.
Extrem, ich glaube, sie sind von allen Tieren der Welt die schlechtesten Schauspieler.
Ja, nach Delfinen. Delfine sind auch scheiße, sind auch arschlicher, glaube ich.
Ja, ich glaube, die sind einfach zu ehrlich, die können einfach nicht lügen, können die einfach nicht.
Ne, was wolltest du eben sagen?
Du wirst das sagen, das alles...
Naja, also ich würde die Stimmung erstmal direkt runterziehen.
Ja, okay.
Mit einem moralischen Dilemma.
Das hatten wir noch nie, das am Anfang die Stimmung runtergezogen. Naja, das moralische Dilemma, da könnten wir jetzt auch einen Jingle einspielen, okay. Mit einem moralischen Dilemma. Das hatten wir noch nie, dass am Anfang die Stimmung runtergezogen ist. Naja, das moralische Dilemma, da könnten wir jetzt auch einen Jingle einspielen, ja. Wenn Stefan Titzel nicht sagen würde, ich sage, hey, gib mir noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit, dann hätten wir einen coolen Podcast. Und du, nein, ich muss jetzt aufnehmen, ich muss heute noch arbeiten, ich muss heute noch irgendwie eine Bombenwarnung aussprechen. Gestern war hier Bombenwarnung. Ja, ja, ja, ja, auf jeden Fall war ich in einem Restaurant, und es gibt ja Legenden, wenn man in einem Restaurant ist und da ist ein Aquarium, was heißt das jetzt eigentlich? Heißt das, die haben besonders gutes Essen? Heißt das, man muss kein Trinkgeld geben? Heißt das, man kann Fische aus dem Aquarium essen und man kann sich die aussuchen, bestellen und dann kann man darauf zeigen und dann nehmen die das? Und dann gab es einen Fisch, der war krank und der hatte am Auge, hatte der so einen Pilz. Und der war recht gross, also er hat fast ausgesehen, als hätte er zwei Köpfe, ich übertreibe ein wenig, und der hatte echt tatsächlich einen grossen Pilz an den Augen, war irgendwie entzündet und es sah echt unangenehm aus, sah auch echt unappetitlich aus. Und dann habe ich mich bei dem Gedanken erwischt, naja, muss man jetzt so einen Fisch in einem Restaurant haben, wo man ja eigentlich nichts Unappetitliches haben möchte. Konnte man da auch essen oder war das so ein Takeaway-Restaurant? Ne, man konnte da auch essen, wir haben da auch gegessen. Dann finde ich es unappetitlich. Ja, aber die Frage ist, sollte man diesen Fisch aus dem Verkehr ziehen. Ja, aber ist das nicht moralisch fragwürdig, den er nur, weil er unappetitlich aussieht, aus dem Verkehr zu ziehen? Er hat ja auch als Fisch eine Würde. Du würdest ja auch nicht einem Menschen, der scheiße aussieht, in einem Restaurant verbieten, dass er da essen darf. Bei Tinder werden jetzt Leute, die über 30 sind, müssen jetzt bezahlen. Das ist genau das gleiche Prinzip. Es ist das gleiche, es ist das gleiche, es ist, du sagst gar nichts mehr, es ist das gleiche Prinzip. Bei Menschen, gewisse Lebewesen passen halt nicht in gewisseen, und da muss man sie aus dem Verkehr ziehen, damit es wieder einwandfrei
läuft. Und dieser Fisch hat offensichtlich
den Zenit überschritten schon längst.
Er hat den Shark
gejumpt. Als Fisch quasi.
Okay, also du meinst, er hat sich nicht zusammengerissen,
er hat sich nicht richtig angestrengt, die hohen
Leistungsmaßnahmen gar nicht. Man kann sich auch mal die Hände waschen, man kann sich das
Gesicht mal waschen, gerade wenn man im Wasser ist, ist es jetzt
nicht so schwierig, dass man keinen Pilz bekommt, oder?
Ja, das stimmt. Meine Fresse. Gehen Tiere ehrlich auch an Land, um sich zu waschen, gerade wenn man im Wasser ist, ist es jetzt nicht so schwierig, dass man keinen Pilz bekommt, oder? Ja, das stimmt, da hast du schon recht. Meine Fresse. Gehen Tiere ehrlich auch an Land, um sich zu waschen? Scheiße Fische. Wie machen sich Fische eigentlich sauber? Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, das ist mit ein sehr großes Problem. Ja, Fische haben viele Probleme. Fische sind echt ein Comedy-Thema, muss man mal ganz ehrlich sagen. Aber wirklich, hat sich mal jemand Gedanken gemacht, was im Ozean eigentlich so abgeht, jeden Tag? Ja, die Autoren von Spongebob Spongebob, Spongebob. Die können auch wirklich tauchen, um sich Inspiration zu sammeln. Eine Koralle, stimmt, wir können eine Folge über eine Koralle machen. Nein, die haben ihren Writer's Room im Autorenraum, wo sie sich immer Ideen ausdenken, haben die, glaube ich, im Sea Life, im Sea Life Center, glaube ich. Absolut. Haben dann alle so Flaschen auf und haben dann so Magnettafeln, mit denen sie auch unter Wasser kommunizieren können. Warst du schon beim Sea-Life? Ja. Naja, also wenn ich jetzt beim FBI arbeiten würde und ich mir entscheiden müsste, ob du jetzt gelogen hast oder nicht. Die Betonung war klar Nein, der Inhalt war klar Ja. Ja. Wie macht man das? Ja. Also etwas als nein zu betonen. Kann man auch nein zu sagen. Ja klar, man kann betonen, ja sagen. Nein, nein, nein. Genau so, da wird man den Kopf schüttelt, ja sagen. Haben Sie, als Sie in die Bank eingebrochen sind, ein Selfie von sich vor dem verängstigten Bankschalter gemacht, schüttelt den Kopf, ja, sowas. Sehr gut gelöst. Ich habe die ganze Zeit überlegt, wie löst er das jetzt? Weiss er, dass wir im Radio sind und man es nicht sehen kann. Ich habe die Regieanweisung gesprochen. Wir sollten viel häufiger Regieanweisungen machen. Regieanweisungen sind der Shit, die sind total lustig. Ja, grossartig. Es ist wie, auch in Büchern kommen die mir manchmal, na gut, eigentlich, na ja, gut, mal wieder ein bisschen zu schnell gesprochen. Bisschen rückwärts, ne, ein bisschen langsam. Du bist heute auch im Speedmodus. Ne, ich bin nicht langsam, ich bin im Speedmodus. Ja. Ich war schon mal im Slap-Send, das war nicht gelogen, du wärst ein mieser FBI-Agent. Ich habe wahnsinnig, ich habe nur keine Erinnerung mehr daran und deswegen dachte ich mir, bevor ich jetzt ausführe. Aber es ist eigentlich fast dasselbe, ob man nie da war oder sich nur nicht daran erinnern kann, ist im Grunde dasselbe.
Das ist wie bei dir und Schule.
Naja, es sind halt Fische, es sind halt Fische überall.
Und du gehst halt durch Tunnel, dann sind da Haie manchmal.
Und man war als Kind immer schon ein bisschen enttäuscht, dass die Haie halt nicht so gross waren, wie man sie erwartet hätte.
Und ich war auch ein sehr anstrengendes Kind, ich musste halt immer unterhalten werden.
Und dann waren halt sehr kleine Haie, dann dachte ich mir immer mal, oh, ist das langweilig.
Und dann habe ich angefangen, auf den Gegenden das Aquarium zu donnern und so. Ach Gott, ich kann mich dir als Kind so gut vorstellen. Einfach konstant gelangweilt. Schon wieder Weihnachten, ey, wie letztes Jahr, boring. Einmal habe ich einen Wunschzettel gefunden, habe ich schon mal erzählt, glaube ich, wo ich mir 17 Pfeile gewünscht hätte. Für deine 17 Erzfeile. Wenn ichums machen, die haben dann so ein, ich kann das gar nicht nachmachen, so Au oder sowas, so ein Jauchzen, was man in Deutschland einfach nie machen würde. Im Lachen, meinst du das, im Lachen? Ja, auch, aber auch so als positive Kondom. Mir ist mal aufgefallen, dass bei King of Queens zum Beispiel, die haben den gleichen Lacher benutzt wie andere Sitcoms, und man hat dann immer, eine Frau hat eine, es ist ziemlich blöd, eine Frau drin zu haben, die eine sehr spezielle Lacher hat, für eine Aufnahme von Lachern, die man öfter benutzt. Weil man hört, glaube ich, bei Two and a Half Men und King of Queens und anderen Friends, glaube ich auch, da hört man so eine Frau, die immer so ganz speziell lacht und die man wirklich in jeder Folge dieser drei Serien hört. Das war ich, ja. Mein Name war das. Ja, aber kann ja auch einfach sein, dass sie sehr gerne im Publikum sitzt, dass sie bei vielen von diesen Veranstaltungen dabei ist. Kann ja auch sein. Dass sie bei jeder Aufzeichnung sitzt. Ja, kann auch sein. Nee, aber ich glaube, das ist sowas ganz, ich habe mir auch mal so ein Video gesehen, also könnt ihr euch mal an, vielleicht findet ihr es sogar, ich finde es immer total toll, mit Leuten über Videos zu reden, die beide gesehen haben, weil das ist sowas Intimes irgendwie, gerade bei YouTube. Was ich sagen will, früher gab es gewisse Filme und Musik, die hat jeder gehört. Ja, irgendwie so Der Weisse Hai hat jeder gesehen, Star Wars. Man musste gar nicht fragen, ob man den gesehen hat, weil man konnte davon ausgehen. Star Wars 1 und 2 und 3. Star Wars 3. Es gab sechs Filme. Es gab schon sechs.
Ja, aber heutzutage ist das nicht mehr so. Man kann heutzutage nicht mehr sagen, ey, hast du diese Serie gesehen? Weil es gibt so viele Serien oder halt auch gerade bei YouTube-Videos, auch YouTube-Videos, die wahnsinnig viele Klicks haben, kann man nicht davon ausgehen, dass sie jeder gesehen hat. Und es gibt einfach nicht mehr diesen Generalkonsens, dass alle dasselbe konsumieren, sondern jeder hat seine individuellen Geschmäcker. Und deswegen finde ich es ganz toll, mich mit jemandem zu unterhalten, der dieselben Videos gesehen hat, wie ich und auch so ganz spezielle Videos, weil das so was ganz Intimes ist, wo man teilt einen Teil seiner Freizeit. Ich finde es auch immer ganz toll, wenn man eine Serie zu Ende geguckt hat und dann fährt man immer in so ein Loch. Also ich fange immer in so ein Loch. Ich finde es immer traurig. Wegen der Bombenwarnung oder was? Das ist der schlechteste Gag in elf Folgen Podcast-Ufo. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Hier ist er, ich stand gewonnen. Dankeschön, vielen Dank. Danke, ich bin die ganze Woche noch hier, Autokamikos alle volle Stunde. Es ist halt so, dass ich in so einem Lochfallland immer nachserien, weil ich mir denke, ja, ich habe Freunde dazugewonnen. Ich habe Freunde dazugewonnen, die ich... Sind Strassen bei euch schlecht, oder wie? Und schon wieder, der Award geht schon wieder weiter, dieses Mal an, Bochentinhentin will herzlichen Glückwunsch yes dankeschön vielen dank und ich habe immer das gefühl dass ich Freunde verliere wenn die Serie vorbei ist deswegen findest du sie nicht mehr oder was und da ist der award nur drei ich glaube genau jetzt sind die Nachbarn von mir genervt dass ich nicht immer so rumbrüllen. Ja, nicht nur die. Ja, red weiter. Woo, woo, ja, das finde ich auch, den fand ich auch am besten, den mag ich auch nicht und diese Wendung fand ich auch scheiße, das ist immer ganz toll. Ich glaube, dass über Serien reden ist. Ich finde es so geil, dass wir schon mittlerweile dabei sind, darüber zu reden, wie wir über Themen reden, anstatt über Themen zu reden. Es ist immer ganz toll, über Serien zu reden, wir können auch einfach über Serien reden, aber das machen wir nicht, das ist uncool. Was ich sagen wollte. Ich würde auch sagen, das ist das Neue, über das Wetter reden. Wie gesagt, wir fangen ja in der Podcast-Folge auch nicht an mit, hör mal, boah, es ist warm geworden, ne, über das Wochenende. Worüber reden eigentlich Wolken? Das erklärt die Ads Florentin Will. Auch über das Wetter, weil die sind ja Wetter. Also es ist ein Kompliment für eine Wolke, wenn man sagt, hey, heute ist schönes Wetter? Also wenn ein Wolkenpärchen miteinander flirtet, ist es dann so, hey, heute ist aber gutes Wetter draußen. Aber eigentlich sind ja Wolken immer nur dann, wenn schlechtes Wetter ist. Gutes Wetter heißt ja Abwesenheit von Wolken, von daher schwierig. Worüber reden Wolken? Weil die wissen ja schon. Und Planeten, worüber reden Planeten? Ja, gute Frage. Es dreht sich nicht immer alles um dich, Sonne. Fuck you! Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam! Der beste Gag. Und der beste Gag geht auch an Florendin Will. Dankeschön, vielen Dank, 4 zu 0. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Vielen Dank. Worauf ich ursprünglich hinaus wollte, ich habe ein YouTube-Video gesehen von so einem Xylophon-Mann, der Xylophon, der so ein Mädchen gespielt hat. Der Xylophon-Mann geht ans Telefon ran. Bekehender Song von Helge Schneider. Ja, und der hat Xylophone gespielt auf seinem Xylophon, hat das Lied Xylophon gespielt und hat die Noten X, Y und dann Fiss, das wird vielleicht eher was für Musikinsider, gespielt. Und es war wirklich in so einem Klassenraum, wo wirklich komplett Stille war. Und er hat irgendwie als sein Musikabschlusswort, ach, ich keine Ahnung, warum muss man immer spekulieren? Warum kann man nicht einfach sagen, was man sieht? Warum muss man sich immer die Geschichte dazu ausdenken? Das können die Leute doch auch selber. Hör mal auf. Also, die war dann irgendwie, hat dann in seinem Klassenzimmer gespielt und dann war halt die ganze Klasse da und hat zugehört. Vielleicht war der Lehrer gerade nicht da oder vielleicht, ne, meistens nicht, ist auch völlig egal. Auf jeden Fall war es so, dass die ganzen Schüler haben zugehört und fanden es anscheinend total toll. Allerdings wollte eine Schülerin ihr Glücksgefühl immer wieder ausdrücken, indem sie so komisch gejauchzt hat und ununterbrochen. Und dann dachte ich mir, das ist vielleicht in der Situation uncool, aber das wurde gefilmt und hat irgendwie 15 Millionen Klicks, weil der super gut Xylophon spielen kann, und jeder kommentiert und sagt, halte, halte die Fresse, du musst nicht alle drei Sekunden, wuh, wuh, wuh, gerade bei der musikalischen Darbietung ist es echt nervig, wenn jemand ständig zwischenruft. Und das denke ich mir auch, da sind wir heute in unserer Gesellschaft. Ich will auch noch ein Wort zur Gesellschaft sagen. Es ist ja heute nicht mehr so, dass man für sich selbst lebt, man lebt ja für die gesamte Welt. Man könnte jeden Moment gefilmt werden und 15 Millionen Klicks haben auf YouTube. Kann ja sein. Also benehmt euch dementsprechend bitte anständig. Ja, Leute, die früher scheiße waren, fanden fünf Leute scheiße, heute finden sie fünf Millionen Leute scheiße. Genau, also man muss sich in jeder Situation bewusst sein, kann ich wollen, dass das, was ich gerade tue,
500 Millionen Klicks
im Internet hat. Das ist der neue kategorische Imperativ.
Das ist der Stefans
kategorischer Imperativ. Handle immer nach
der Maxime, die auch in einem viralen YouTube-Video
funktionieren würde. Das ist
Kant 2.0, das funktioniert.
Das ist sehr gut. Aber glaubst du, dass
wir heute extremer leben,
also dass durch soziale Medien und die Öffentlichkeit die konstante gewisse Emotionen multipliziert werden?
Na, ich glaube, dass die meisten Leute relativ viel gelangweiter sind als vorher noch, weil man hat alles schon mal gesehen, man hat durch Internet hat man schon viel mehr gesehen und hat schon viel mehr Kultur kennengelernt, man hat viel mehr Extreme kennengelernt, man weiss schon, also auch durch Serienkonsum, wo man ja auch sehr viele Themen, sich in Themen reindenkt, also ich weiß nicht, Game of Thrones, Mittelalter und so, Chemie halt bei Breaking Bad, man weiss halt schon, also man lernt durch Serien, guckt man sich auch sehr viel Wissen an und deswegen glaube ich, man ist relativ gelangweilt von Dingen, also wenn jetzt ein Chemielehrer irgendwie anfängt, dann so Tabletten aufzulösen, wo früher Leute applaudiert haben, wow, die Tablette ist weg, wo ist die hier, wow, ist jetzt mittlerweile nur noch so ein, ja, hey, ich habe schon mal jemanden gesehen, der Christian Mass gekocht hat. Meinst du nicht, dadurch wird irgendwie Interesse noch weiter angeregt, dass wenn man sich eine Mittelalter-Serie anschaut, dass man sich dann weiter in dieses Thema hinein arbeitet und ein grösseres Selbstbewusstsein und eine Sensitivität dafür entwickelt? Nein, da bist du, glaube ich, auf dem Holzweg. Denk da nochmal drüber nach, im Stellen. Okay, ich tu mir leid, ich wollte nochmal. Es fällt mir häufiger auf, dass irgendwelche Kommentare von dir kommen, die nicht so richtig durchdacht sind. Ja, das stimmt. Ich wende die Florentin-Will-Methoden an. Einfach beleidigen. Einfach beleidigen und kurz, wenn man was auffällt, einfach mal. Das fühlt sich nicht gut an. Nee, oder? Das ist nämlich auch das immer. Wir sollten netter zueinander sein. Das ganze Comedy-Potential, was wir aber eh nicht ausnutzen, ist dann halt weg. Wir benutzen sowieso nur 15 Prozent. Ich glaube, das war sogar eine Studie. Der Mensch verwendet nur 10 Prozent seines Comedy-Potentials im normalen Leben. Ist tatsächlich so. Außer Scarlett Johansson in Lucy, die benutzt fünf Prozent ihres Comedy-Potentials. Ich habe ja letztens Whiplash gesehen, ich weiß nicht, ob du den Film kennst, aber da geht es darum, wie ein junger Um Schlagzeugzeugen. Ja, richtig. Also wie ein junger Schlagzeugstudent durch einen sehr harten und herrischen Lehrer zu Höchstleistungen getrieben wird. Und der Lehrer macht ihn halt komplett fertig, aber dadurch wird er zu Höchstleistungen angetrieben. Und es ist eigentlich immer schön, jemandem dabei zuzuschauen, wie er sich richtig reinarbeitet und egal und seine Hände bluten schon, aber er arbeitet weiter und er pusht sich selber übers Limit hinaus und am Ende kommt er dann, das ist irgendwas, wo man gerne bei sich schaut. Am Ende stimmt ein Burnout, aber ist halt ... Ja, genau, das ist tatsächlich so die zweischneidige Botschaft des Films. Aber ich dachte mir, man kann ja sowas auch nicht mit allen Berufsgruppen machen. Also so Sportler oder Musiker, also auch Black Swan mit Ballett, da funktioniert das alles sehr gut, aber mach das mal mit einem Comedian. Also mach mal einen Film über den Comedian, und dann hast du so Montagen, wie ihr ganzen Tag irgendwie Gags schreibt und dann lacht niemand und dann macht das nochmal, dann lachen die ein bisschen. Du musst ja gut drauf sein, um Gag abzuliefern, aber du wirst ja nicht besser dadurch, wenn dir niemand sagt, das ist scheiße, was du machst und Kritik zieht dich aber runter, ist halt normal, ist halt normal, Menschen wollen halt gut gefunden werden, wenn sie nicht gut gefunden werden, dann sind sie traurig und wenn sie traurig sind, dann können sie nicht abliefern, das ist so eine Abwärtsspirale, die ein Comedian immer so nach unten zieht. Und da muss man dann auch, da muss man dann rauskommen. Ich rede gerade in eine Tasse rein und es war immer so, dachte ich, dass ich früher in Gangsterfilmen, haben Leute auch oft in Tassen reingeredet, um ihre Stimme zu verzerren. Aber ich klinge gefühlt noch genauso wie vorher. Wirklich? Wirklich? Ja, habe ich schon oft gesehen. Also was ich kenne, dass wenn Leute telefonieren, dass sie eine Krawatte über den Hörer legen, wo ich bis heute nicht verstanden habe, was es bringen soll. Also hilft das? Also ich rede gerade in den Tassel rein, weil TKKG hat man an Bösewicht in den Tassel reingesprochen und ist eine Aufgabe für euch. Wenn ihr rauskriegt, welche Folge das war, kriegt ihr ein unterschriebenes Florentinville-Filtercafé-Untersetzer. Zwanzig Minuten haben wir gesprochen. Reicht denn auch? Sind das so die Pausen, die du dann später rausschneidest? Ja, es ist schon aufgefallen, die Pausen schneide ich raus. Sammelst du die Sachen dann eigentlich immer, die du rausschneidest? Also gibt es dann auch so einen Outtakes? Nee, es ist meistens nicht, also Outtakes im Sinne von ist noch lustig, schneide ich meistens rein. Also es ist meistens drin geblieben, was dann so unnützlich ist, dass es wieder lustig ist. Was rausfliegt, im Endeffekt sind eigentlich nur sehr, sehr peinliche Pausen, die eigentlich für mich eher peinlich sind. Dinge, die für dich peinlich sind, lasse ich natürlich drin. Das ist klar. Das ist klar. Es wäre aber auch mal lustig, wenn man in einem Film so statt lustige Outtakes einfach so total langweilige Outtakes so, ja, der war nicht lustig genug, nochmal, halt so wirklich die Sachen, die eigentlich keinen interessieren, oh, das Licht war nicht an. Naja, wir bauen es nochmal auf. Also nicht so Sachen, die niemand interessieren. Aber das wirklich auf die DVD rauskommen. So Stellen, wo einfach vergessen wird, das Mikrofon anzumachen. Man hört auch niemanden, weil man hört auch denjenigen, der sagt, wir haben das Mikrofon nicht angemacht. Ja, oder wo man vergisst, die Kamera anzumachen und nur den Ton hat. Nur Schwarz und Ton. Oh, mein Mikrofon ist umgefallen, meine Güte. Entschuldigung. Aber die Leute haben ja die Vorstellung, dass es beim Filmarbeiten extrem viel Spaß macht, weil wenn es klappt, macht man einen coolen Film und wenn es nicht klappt, ist es saulustig wie in den Outtakes, ja, aber eigentlich ist das nur ein kleiner Teil der tatsächlichen Dreharbeiten und es meistens eigentlich rumsitzt. Ich habe mal gehört, es ist sehr viel Warten, es ist sehr viel Warten darauf, dass Dinge aufgebaut werden, dass das Licht stimmt und so und das ist halt ein Handwerk, das ist was viele Leute unterschätzen, eschätzen. Glaubst du wirklich, dass es viele Leute unterschätzen? Du sagst es immer so, du sagst es immer, dass es viele Leute unterschätzen, dass es so eine ... Oh, da kommt wieder die Floridin-Bild-Peitsche. Nein, ich will einfach heute mal ein bisschen auf die Fakten arbeiten. Toll, hey! Da kommt mal ein bisschen auf die Fakten achten, weil ich finde es nicht so cool, dass du ständig solche Sachen ... Oder der überbenutzteste Begriff ist auch immer mehr. Dieses immer mehr Jugendliche spielen Killerspiele.
Dieses einfach nur, ich will über ein Thema reden,
um uns den Anschein eines aktuellen
Anlasses zu geben,
tue ich so, als würde es einen akuten Anstieg
davon geben, was nicht stimmt.
Auch so Wörter
wie vielleicht zum Beispiel,
wo man auch immer dann Thesen raushauen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich jetzt diesen Satz wieder rauskomme.
Das ist echt furchtbar.
Leute, verwendet niemals das Wort vielleicht vor Thesen. Niemals.
Dafür ist es nicht gemacht worden.
Thesen und vielleicht sind wie komplett zwei verschiedene Welten.
Wenn die aufeinander prallen, explodiert das Universum. Das funktioniert nicht.
Boah, ich bin sehr krank. Jetzt muss ich gerade mal kurz ansprechen.
Du bist ständig krank. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Seitdem ich diesen Podcast auf mir nehme, bin ich nicht mehr gesund geworden. Wie geht das jetzt schon wieder? Ich denke, du hast es gerne hingekriegt. Ach fuck, ey, wieso habe ich jetzt den Ton gehört? Es kann gut sein, dass ich in den nächsten vierzig Minuten versterbe.
Das Tolle ist, man merkt überhaupt nicht, dass wir gar keine Themen haben heute.
Weil wir eigentlich nicht ganz gut drauf waren bis jetzt. Aber genau jetzt ist glaube ich der Punkt, wo man merkt, dass wir keine Themen haben. Wo man sich halt, wo man ein Thema halt als roten Faden benutzen konnte, konnte, konnte, konnte haben werden. Aber ja, jetzt haben wir halt diesen nicht.
Was sieht man hier am Wochenende an? Was steht bei dir am Wochenende an? Ist tatsächlich, aber kennst du das auch? Das ist ein Privatgespräch daraus. Aber ich finde es immer ganz geil, wenn man im Alltag gefragt wird, und wie war dein Wochenende und du denkst zurück,, so, was war gestern und vorgestern, und in deinem Gedächtnis hast du einfach nur zwei schwarze Tage, komplett leer, ohne Inhalt, weil, ähm, weil halt so ein bisschen gechillt sind, überhaupt keine Ahnung. Aber da frage ich mich wirklich, ob da wirklich Leute, ich denke ja immer, dass die Leute, die das fragen, dass sie das wissen noch, was sie gemacht haben. Also liegt es an uns, haben wir vielleicht Gedächtnisprobleme oder so? Also ich habe nämlich das auch, wenn mich die Leute fragen, dann weiß ich, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, was passiert. Du musst erst mal eine halbe Stunde darüber nachdenken, bis mir dann eingefallen ist, dass ich im Sea-Life-Center war und Fische angeguckt habe oder so. Und ich kann mich da nicht daran erinnern. Ich blende Tage aus, wenn der Tag vorbei ist, ist er vorbei und dann kommt der nächste halt. Aber Leute, die das fragen, die haben aktiv darüber nachgedacht und wissen das wahrscheinlich auch. Ja, vor allem das ist so ein natürlicher Kompressor. Also sowohl die langweiligsten als auch die aufregendsten Erfahrungen werden einfach gecancelt, weil wenn du zu hart feierst oder so, kannst du dich nicht mehr daran erinnern, aber wenn du den ganzen Tag nur auf dem Sofa liegst und Käse isst, kannst du dich auch nicht mehr daran erinnern. Also das heißt, die menschliche Psyche zwingt dich zum Mittelmaß. Deine Assoziation ist auf dem Sofa liegen und Käse essen. Ja. Beschreib das mal. Beschreib dich mal. Ich habe natürlich verschiedene Käsesorten. Hast du so eine Käseplatte? Stellst du dir so eine Käseplatte zusammen mit Brie und Gouda und Butterkäse? Nein, überhaupt nicht. Alles noch in der Verpackung. Dann mache ich die Verpackung auf und dann denke ich mir, das war das Beste, aber auch. Ich habe meinen Mitbewohner, weil mein Mitbewohner ist sehr knallharte Aufschnittfliege. Ganz kurz, du kannst die Geschichte nicht anfangen mit das Beste war auch. Erstmal, es ist relativ unwahrscheinlich. Es sind schon sehr viele Dinge, wie gesagt, es sind schon auf dieser Welt sehr viele Dinge passiert. Dass es das Beste war, was jemals passiert ist, ist sehr unwahrscheinlich. Ey, was auch ganz okay war. Mein Mitbewohner hat immer wahnsinnig viele Aufschnitte und so und wirklich in diesen Plastikverpackungen, wo dann immer drei Scheiben drin sind. Und davon hat er 30 Stück in seinem Kühlschrank und in unserem Kühlschrank. Und ich habe ihn mal gefragt, ob ich mir eine Scheibe Käse ausleiten könnte, also haben könnte, weil ich gerade was gekocht habe, wo ich Käse gebraucht habe. Was kocht man, wo man Käse braucht? Ich bin ganz gespannt. Asianudeln. Und das war dann so, da war die Aufschlusspackung aber noch voll und verschlossen. Ich kann dir folgen, ich muss keine Pause machen, das war ja nicht so schwer, ich kann dir folgen. Und dann habe ich die aufgemacht und habe eine Scheibe rausgenommen, damit gekocht und sie dann wieder zurückgetan. Und am nächsten Morgen komme ich in die Küche und will irgendwas machen, will irgendwas in den Mülleimer werfen und sehe, wie im Mülleimer einfach die Aufschnittpackung noch randgefüllt bis auf eine Scheibe im Müll liegt. Und ich musste so lachen. Ich lag wirklich kurzzeitig am Boden, weil ich so lachen musste. Allein die Vorstellung, dass mein Mitwohner, wenn ich nur eine Scheibe rausnehme, er den Rest einfach wegschmeißt, fand ich so lustig. Es spricht überhaupt nicht für dich, es spricht so krass gegen dich. Überhaupt nicht, aber ganz kurz nochmal zum Thema Anekdoten, die ins nichts führen. Ich finde, es gibt nichts Schöneres, als wenn dir Leute Anekdoten erzählen, die einfach ins nichts führen und wo man einfach denkt, was für langweilige Leben müssen diese Menschen leben, dass sie das als, gut, ich habe gerade die Anekdote erzählt, wie ich Müll und Käse gefunden habe, aber trotzdem, jemand letztens erzählt, da war ich in so einem Club und dann hat mich jemand angerufen und dann habe ich aber kaum was verstanden und dann habe ich gesagt, hey, hier im Club ist es so laut und dann habe ich das Handy so hochgehalten, damit die Person hört, wie laut es im Club ist. Das ist genau wie dieser... What? Was? Das war alles? Das ist echt scheiße. Und solche Leute, die stehen dann auch wertvolle Lebenszeit. Wenn du mir denkst, also wenn man vom Fernsehen kommt und man weiss, wie viel eine Minute Fernsehen kostet, da weiss ich auch nicht, keine Ahnung. Wie viel Arbeiter auch reinfiehst. Es ist sau viel, es steckt in so eine Minute Fernsehen. Und man denkt, also wie wertvolle Minuten sein können und dann redet einer mit einem fünf Minuten lang und es führt ins nichts. Und es ist so eine Geschichte wie, ja, ich habe ihn gefragt, willst du noch Wasser, und er hat gesagt, ja, und ich habe gesagt, okay, was ist das denn? Das sind 30 Sekunden, die völlig ins Nichts laufen und wo ein Fernsehender auch tausend Euro für bezahlt hätte, weil die Zeit auch so viel wert ist. Ja, aber vor allem das Nichtverständnis des Aufbaus eine Anekdote. Einfach, dass die Pointe zum Beispiel komplett fehlt. Nein, aber das ist die Pointe einfach fehlt. Das habe ich auch nicht. Nee, aber das ist eine Pointe schon zu irgendwas führen. Das finde ich schon. Ja, ich habe ihn gefragt, ob er noch Wasser will, und er hat gesagt, nein, er hat gesagt, ja, aber dann hatten wir kein Wasser mehr. What? Wie soll man dann reagieren? Das ist immer so, wie wenn ein Lehrer einen Witz erzählt, man weiß nicht, wann man lachen soll, aber man weiß genau, er wird nicht lustig sein, man will aber trotzdem lachen, aber man muss so ein bisschen von der Tonlage erraten, wann es aufhört. Das ist dann auch immer. Es ist aber meistens auch, wie man Geschichten erzählt. Also du kannst so eine Geschichte auch lustig erzählen, wenn du sagst, hey, aber es reicht oft schon, mit Lachen ins Gespräch zu gehen. Das ist auch dein Ziel, mit dem. Hey, Leute! Hey, wir hatten Wasser. Wir hatten Wasser, ey. Stell dir das mal vor, wir ... Das ist auch wie man das betont. Wir hatten Wasser. Wir hatten Wasser. Und was ist dann passiert? Ja, und dann war ein Kumpel da. Ey, also ohne Scheiss, ey, was mir letztens passiert ist, ey, das glaubst du nicht. Also erstens war da, Ronny war da, ja, du kennst ja Ronny, ne? Also wenn der da ist, dann weiss man, die Nacht wird crazy, okay, Ronny war da, Betty war da, okay? Nicht die Betty, sondern die andere Betty. Die andere, die ist direkt, die mit Ronny aber auch mal den Heißluftballon, und dem Heiratsantrag auf dem Heissluftballon und diese peinlichen 20 Minuten zurück. Genau, da gab es, danke, dass ich den schon nicht mehr verwenden kann, da gab es echt, aber das ist ja eh krass, zwischen Ronny und Betty ist ja eh immer so ein bisschen hin und her, du kennst die beiden ja. Auf jeden Fall die beiden, ja irgendwie so ein bisschen zwischen Liebe und Hass, du kennst es ja. Auf jeden Fall ich halt irgendwie, hallo Leute, was geht und so, haben sich überhaupt nicht angekündigt, standen plötzlich vor meiner Tür, ich sag, what, was ist hier los und sie, hey, wir wollten nur kurz vorbeinkommen, wir machen keiner dagegen, ich so, ja klar, komm rein, meine Tür ist immer offen, Alter, ey, ich dachte mir schon, what the fuck, was machen die beiden überhaupt zusammen, also sind die beiden zusammen unterwegs, was ist hier los, Wie ist das zu stehen gekommen? Also was geht da ab? Und ich so, ja klar, kommt rein. Und dann so Betty, ohne Witz, kaum ist sie in der Wohnung und sagt hi. Und weißt du, was sie dann gesagt hat? Ob du Wasser willst. Sie hat echt ohne Witz gefragt, habt ihr was zu trinken? Und ich dachte mir, what? Alter, was geht denn gerade jetzt ab? So ist so krass drauf im Moment, das hat sie bei Tom auch neulich gemacht und er ist völlig vom Song gefallen. Ich weiss, und Tom hat es mir erzählt und ich habe gesagt, no fucking way, no fucking way, das hat die nicht echt gemacht, aber dann war sie in meiner Wohnung und hat mich, halt mich, ja, und du kennst mich in solchen Situationen, ja, aber sie hat halt mich gefragt, das war halt das Lustigste, sie hat halt nicht irgendwie Tom gefragt oder Carsten, die halt auch zufällig da war, nein, sie fragt mich und ich so, what, okay, erstmal, lass mir natürlich nichts anmerken, klar, lass mir nichts anmerken, sagt, ich guck mal nach, ja, halt, was soll ich sagen, ja, es war mir halt sau unangenehm, es war mir halt sau unangenehm, ich fragge so, ey, was soll ich machen irgendwie? Und Tom, beziehungsweise Ronny hat sie halt angeschaut. Alter, da dachte ich mir, jetzt geht das wieder los. Also ich auf jeden Fall direkt in die Küche. Denkt mir, fuck, was mache ich jetzt, okay? Was ist los, was habe ich da? Ja, ich hatte noch eine halbe Flasche Fanta da, komplett ohne Kohlensäure. Ja, boah, wie ich das hasse. Ein Stück Aufschnittkäse im Kühlschrank. Ein bisschen Aufschnittkäse lag noch im Mülleimer. Ich habe ihn erst mal aus dem Mülleimer zurück in den Kühlschrank getan. Ich hatte noch Eier da, wusste nicht, wie lange die noch haltbar sind. Auf jeden Fall, ich halt so zurück ins Wohnzimmer. Weißt du, was in der Zwischenzeit passiert ist? Nee, was hast du dir gemacht? Ronny zieht sich die Schuhe aus. Waaaaaa! Alter, ich dachte, what? Was ist ... also ... Die sind so crazy drauf, ey, die sind so krass drauf, was ist das? Die Worte haben mir gefehlt, ich so, okay. Aber was ist denn da passiert? Ich weiss nicht, ich weiss es nicht. Und vor allem, ich kenne ja Ronny halt schon echt lange. Ja, man, nicht so, als würde ich das erste Mal kennen. Aber seit er mit Betty zusammen war, dreht er komplett durch. Man kann mit ihm kaum noch normal reden. Und ich so, ja, komm rein, mach sie gemütlich. Ich muss halt irgendwas sagen. Weißt du, was Tom noch erzählt hat? Vor der Geschichte mit dem Wasser, da hat er nämlich, Ronny ist nämlich dann reingekommen, hatte eine Kappe auf und dann hat er in der Wohnung, doch, er hat sie angelassen. Er hat die Kappe angelassen und hat dann noch, während die Geschichte dann mit dem Wasser richtig in Gang kam, hat er sie, und das fand ich das Krasseste, umgedreht. Das war so gelös. Alter, das glaubt ja kein Mensch. Du musst Ronny halt kennen, man muss Ronny kennen. Man muss dabei gewinnen seinenden sein. Man muss da beigewenden sein. Das ist halt echt krass. Und auf jeden Fall ich halt so, ja klar, komm rein, setzt euch und so. Ey, ich glaube, ich war so fertig am Ende. Ich war am Ende so kaputt. Ich dachte mir, was ist denn jetzt los? Also krass, ne? Aber das ist halt echt passiert, ne? Cut. Ich würde uns eine drei Minus geben. Dankeschön. Wir wollen ja heute auch über Marketing sprechen. Wir haben ja verschiedene Marketingstrategien schon probiert. Schritt eins ist Guerilla-Marketing, anderes Wort für gar kein Marketing. Hat nicht geklappt. Und andere Strategien wollen wir heute vielleicht mal ein bisschen ausprobieren. Aber erst mal, wie stehst du zum Marketing, also was ist für dich wichtig für gutes Marketing, wie bewertest du Marketing, brauchen wir überhaupt Marketing oder?
Also ich dachte immer, dass Marketing was ist, was mich sehr interessiert, weil ich finde das immer ganz interessant, ich bin auch sehr anfällig für Werbung, was ich glaube immer erzählt und es ist halt schon ganz cool, also du kannst halt ein wahnsinnig langweiliges Produkt, kannst du total geil darstellen plötzlich, einfach wenn der Lifestyle darum stimmt, wenn du halt so eine Geschichte darum strickst und ich glaube, es macht wahnsinnig Spaß als Marketing-Typ, da was zu machen, aber ich glaube, ich habe das nämlich jetzt mal als Fach gehabt, als Kurs im Semester und das war echt ganz schön boring, also es ist halt auch irgendwie Handwerk und da musst du halt so Modelle auswendig lernen und sowas, das ist dann scheiße.
Aber ich glaube, wenn man selber was macht und
weg von diesen ganzen Modellen geht
und selber mal überlegt, was man so machen kann,
dann ist es, glaube ich, ganz cool.
Ich hasse diese Fragen immer.
Naja. Ich hasse es, wenn mir
Fragen gestellt werden. Ja, ich dachte, du kennst dich
da gut aus. Nein, überhaupt gar nicht, Alter.
Also, nein, aber die Frage ist, wie sollen wir unseren Podcast
vermarkten? Wir haben jetzt Flyer verteilt, wir haben Buttons verteilt und wir haben so Sticker verteilt. Wo ich mich frage, bis heute frage, wer kauft eigentlich diese Sticker? Wer sagt, wir haben eine Band, wir haben eine Undercover-Coverband, wir haben eine Underground-Coverband von O2-Songs. Eine Undercover-Band, uns kennt keiner. Das ist der Dreck. Ja, genau, aber das ist auch der Sinn der Sache. Das ist auch der Sinn der Sache.
Nee, auf jeden Fall wirklich, wer, wer, wer, also hast du schon jemals eine Band entdeckt durch so einen Sticker auf einer Ampel oder so?
Nee, aber wir hatten sehr viele, ich habe damals selber in einer Band gespielt und wir hatten sehr viele Sticker.
Also wir hatten fast alle unsere Cases mit Stickern beklebt, weil alle Bands Sticker verteilen.
Das ist so das Ding.
Und wir hatten auch selber Sticker.
Aber das ist doch, das ist doch reines Gegenseitig... Also das funktioniert doch nicht. Ich meine, ich glaube, die einzigen, die Bands entdecken durch diese Sticker sind Marketingleute, die diese Sticker verkaufen wollen. Oder Autisten. Wir haben einen Autisten in der Stufe gehabt und der hat immer sehr genau die Wände beobachtet oder sehr genau, sehr langsam ist er über den Boden gegangen, hat immer den Boden beobachtet. Und ich glaube, Leute, die an Autismus leiden, gucken sich Sticker genauer an. Okay, also könnte das eine Zielgruppe werden, die wir versuchen, mit Marketing aktiv abspäden? Ja, ich glaube, das ist eine Zielgruppe für uns. Ich glaube, das ist die Gruppe, die uns entgegenkommt. Aber ich finde jetzt, wir sollten Folgendes machen. Ich glaube, dass Masse immer siegt. Ich glaube, es ist eine Zielgruppe für uns. Ich glaube, es ist die Gruppe, die uns entgegenkommt. Aber wir, also, ich finde jetzt, wir sollten Folgendes machen. Ich glaube, dass Masse immer siegt. Ich glaube, je mehr du raushaust, umso mehr kannst du potenziell treffen. Wir sollten erstmal Facebook ... Die Shotgun-Taktik. Genau, die Stroh-Flinten-Taktik. Das hast du jetzt da nicht vertan. Wir haben jetzt bei Facebook zum Beispiel, könnten wir Beiträge bewerben, aktiv bewerben, damit viele Leute auf den Podcast aufmerksam werden. Wir könnten zum Beispiel 100 Euro, hey, ist eine Ansehe, wir könnten 100 Euro uns zu Weihnachten wünschen, die dann in einen Beitrag, wo wir uns sehr viel Mühe geben, vielleicht einen PR-Typen noch dran setzen und dann gucken, dass sehr viele Leute diesen Post sehen und sagen, hey, weißt du was, das ist ein Podcast, der mir gefällt, das ist ein Podcast, den ich mir mal eine Woche lang anhören möchte und dann vielleicht nochmal danach und nochmal danach. Das ist unwahrscheinlich. Wir hatten ja auch noch die Twitter-Strategie. Unsere Idee war, wir müssen ja an Leute rangehen, die sich für Podcasts interessieren. Und deswegen schauen wir mal auf Twitter, welche Leute über Podcasts twittern. Wir machen also eine Suche nach dem Wort Podcast und suchen einfach nach allen deutschen Leuten, die nach Podcasts suchen Und dann treten wir einfach mit den Leuten in Kontakt. Wir suchen das persönliche Gespräch, wir stellen mal eine Frage zur Persönlichkeit. Einfach versuchen, in ein Gespräch zu kommen, was ganz unverbindlich ist, sodass die Person so, das ist ein netter, netter Kerl. Und dann kommen die natürlich auf die Idee, uiuiui, hat der vielleicht selber einen Podcast, ja, ist das vielleicht ein Podcast, der da kommuniziert.
Und dann ist der erste Schritt schon getan.
Das Ding ist nur leider, dass Leute da über einen Podcast kommunizieren und meistens
schon in Gesprächen stecken und man halt nur 140 Zeichen hat, quasi sich selber vorzustellen,
aber gleichzeitig auch ins Gespräch reinzukommen.
Also es ist auch sehr schwierig, in 140 Zeichen zu versuchen, einem zu erklären, wer man
ist, ins Gespräch reinzukommen, ohne dass man völlig fehlernplazwirkt. Und das ist halt die Challenge, die wir jetzt zu bewältigen haben. Okay, also ich würde sagen, wir fangen mal an. Was ist denn der erste, einfach mal irgendein Random-Tweet, der sich mit Podcasts beschäftigt? So, ich schreibe einen Luca. Ah, nein, Mon... Was? Ja, ja, ich habe gerade einen Neueren, der vielleicht ein bisschen besser passt. zwar, twittert Tatenrang, 2000 Follower twittert, Power-Webinar, in Klammern, mein eigener Podcast, vierteiliges Webinar für mehr Verkaufserfolg. Also eigentlich genau das, was wir wollen. Hier bietet jemand ein Webseminar an auf podcast-erstellen.com und macht dafür Werbung. Die Frage ist, wie gehen wir jetzt darauf rein? Wie gehen wir auf jemanden ein, der Werbung macht? Wie können wir die Werbung sozusagen... Erstmal Kompliment. Wir müssen erstmal den Zuhörer einholen mit einem Kompliment. Sehr guter Vorschlag. Oder vielen Dank. Vielen Dank dir. Okay. Also, schreibst du oder schreib ich, weil dann schreib ich gerade. Ich sehe ihn gerade nicht. Okay, dann schreib ich. Schreib ich. Komm schon. Okay, wir fangen an mit vielen Dank. Vielen Dank. Oder Chapeau. Chapeau. Grossartig, grossartig. Also Chapeau, Chapeau, Ausrufezeichen, wahrscheinlich falsch geschrieben, grossartig. Ja, und jetzt, okay, Chapeau, vielleicht ist es was Lustiges, vielleicht ein Gag, irgendwas Kleines, also sowas ein kleiner, mehr vielleicht sowas wie Bungie-Hitler. Aber Spaß beiseite. Okay, aber, okay. Aber Spaß beiseite, er ist gemein. Aber Spaß beiseite, Doppelpunkt? Wie geht's weiter? Aber Spaß beiseite, jetzt kommt der Conte, jetzt kommt was, worauf die Leute warten. Chapeau, chapeau, grossartig, aber Spaß beiseite, es war völliger Scheiss. Halt deine Presse und hör unseren Podcast an. Aber Spaß beiseite, vielleicht mit einer ehrlich gemeinten Frage, die Leute mögen es immer, wenn man in ihrer Kompetenz appelliert, wenn man ihr eine Kompetenz voraussagt. Also im Sinne von, du kennst dich ja gut mit X aus, kannst du mir bei meinem X helfen? Kannst du uns vielleicht einen Tipp geben? Du kennst dich gut mit dem Erstellen aus, hör doch mal in unseren bereits Erstellten rein. Okay, Spaß beiseite. Du kennst dich gut mit Erstellen aus. Mit Podcast Erstellen raus, aus, heraus. Mit Podcast Erstellung ein Wort? Ja, Erstellungen. Ist das ein Wort? Erstellung Erstellungen aus, ja, Komma, aber? Aber hör doch mal in unseren bereits Erstellten hinein. Okay, ich glaube,
doch mal in unseren erstellten
hinein. Oh, das passt sogar sehr, sehr
gut bis auf fünf Zeichen und raus.
Wir haben einen Tweet abgefeuert.
Perfekt, es funktioniert.
Es funktioniert, und das mag ich so
an Werbung, dass man direkte Erfolge
sieht, dass man direkt sieht, was
passiert.
Okay, wir haben den nächsten. Nein, ganz kurz, es hat tatsächlich nicht funktioniert, weil ich es falsch geschrieben habe. Nochmal. Okay, überbrücke, jetzt kommt eine Überbrückung. Okay, ich habe jetzt hier einen Luca. Luca schreibt, kann es sein, dass ihr die Podcast-Server von Apple zerstört habt. Laufen sehr langsam bis gar nicht.
Und dann hat er verhashtagt einen Podcast, für den man wohl gerade schreibt.
Da müssen wir jetzt auch drauf antworten. Das ist unser Ding.
Also ich würde sagen, wir fangen erst mal mit dem Smiley an.
Die Leute mögen Smilies, also mit einem guten, mit einem positiven Input.
Also vielleicht den Zwinker-Smiley.
Zwinker-Smiley wird in meinem sozialen Umkreis relativ negativ wahrgenommen. Also antwortest du jetzt oder ich? Ich mach ruhig, ich mach ruhig, ich hab schon. Okay, Zwinker-Smiley vielleicht, sowas in der Richtung. Und dann vielleicht was Modisches. Vielleicht irgendwie die Leute mögen es gerne, wenn man ihre Kleidung ... Heda, Heda, Zwinker-Smiley, Heda, coole Weste, hören die Leute immer gern. Leute hören Westen eigentlich nur, um Komplimente abzugreifen. Aber wir wissen ja jetzt nicht genau, ob er eine Weste anhat. Wir können ja nur von seinem Profilbild ausgehen. Ja, das ist schon klar. Tolles Profilbild. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Das ist nicht tolles Profilbild. Schau mal, der wird wahrscheinlich ständig, das ist wie wenn du eine hübsche Frau sagst, du bist hübsch, das hört die ständig, damit kannst du nicht anfangen, du kannst dir sagen, hey. Es ist aber nicht so schön, also es ist nicht so schön, das Gefühl wird, wenn man das sagt. Es ist schon ziemlich gut, ich würde sagen, ich würde ihn eher modisch, schau mal, wenn du so einen Internet-Nerd, so einen absoluten Internet-Freak, der im Internet lebt, persönlich Kompliment machst, das ist das Grösste der Welt, wenn dir jemand sagt, hey, du bist nicht nur gut online, du bist auch ein wertvoller Mensch ausserhalb des Bildschirms, ich würde sagen, coole Weste. Heda, Zwinker-Smiley, coole Weste. Coole Weste. Und jetzt, das piekst jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen, aber hör dir mal unseren Podcast an. Ich finde, du solltest einen Gang zurückschalten und vielleicht solltest du keine Vorschläge mehr machen, erst mal. Na, verstehst du Interesse wecken? So, da denkt jeder, was ist denn hier los? Nein, die denken, das sind ein Haufen Weirdos, die mich anmachen wollen und ich höre bestimmt nicht diesen Podcast mehr jemals an. Glaube ich nicht, glaube ich nicht. Oh fuck, ich habe es vor allem mit meinem eigenen Account geschrieben. Okay, ich bin der
größte Trottel der Welt.
So bin ich die grösste
Marketinginie
der Welt.
Das ist so, du hast vor allem nur auf
eine Sache zu achten, dass du von deinem
Account an den richtigen schreibst,
und du hast erst das eine, dann das andere.
Systematisch alle Fehler, die du machen konntest, bist du durchgegangen.
Und ich kann ihn nicht löschen. Failed deleting. Okay, fuck. Och Gott, ey, es ist das erste Mal, dass wir Marketing betreiben, dass wir Werbung machen wollen, das funktioniert nicht. Aber wie läuft's mit Luca?
Ich bin schon gegen coole Weste und das piekst vielleicht, kommt vielleicht auch ein bisschen komisch rüber. Wir sollten, es scheint ein junger Kerl zu sein, wir sollten an seine Hobbys appellieren. Was macht ein junger Kerl? Longboard fahren. Longboard fahren. Hey, wollen wir uns mal zum Nest zu pädophil? Wollen wir uns mal... Ich finde coole Weste und es piekt vielleicht auch ein bisschen pädophil. Ich wollte es jetzt nicht sagen, aber es ist schon. Wir fangen schon mit Heda an. Findest du Ärzte jetzt pädophil oder was?
Was? Sag doch ein Arzt immer, das piekst jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen. Heda, ich finde Ärzte auch pädophil. Kinderärzte, wer wird denn Kinderarzt? Scheiße. Heda, kann es sein, dass du den Podcast, das Podcast-UFO noch nicht kennst? Ja, Fallzeichen, dann hör doch mal rein. Ich glaube, so redet die Jugend, ich glaube, so redet die Jugend. Dann hör doch mal rein, wacker, dann hör doch wacker mal rein. Okay, ich mache gleich weiter bei jemandem, der schreibt, Podcast war mega geil, bezieht sich höchstwahrscheinlich auf unseren. Ich fange erstmal an mit einer Regieanweisung, und zwar knallt Tür zu. Du hast deinen immer noch nicht rausgeschickt, du hast deinen noch nicht geschickt. Doch, habe ich. Okay. Knallt Tür zu, erstmal als Regieanweisung, um erstmal einen gewissen Punkt zu setzen. Wem schreibst du jetzt? Ich schreibe jetzt gerade Neil. Neil. Kennst du noch Art Attack früher? Ja. Mit Neil, unser großer Künstler. Ja, ich glaube schon. Er bekommt ganz alltägliche Dinge und macht aus ihnen ein Art Attack Riesenbild. Genau, er hat diese auf den Boden gelegt und von der Vogelperspektive sah es aus wie ein Bild. Genau. Okay, also ich schreibe mal, knallt die Tür zu. Sehr gut. Wir suchen noch jemanden. Knallt die Tür zu ist vor allem das Uneinladenste, was man überhaupt machen kann. Wir suchen noch jemanden, der unseren Podcast gut findet. Hättest du Interesse? Sehr gut, sehr gut. Ich schreibe jetzt einem Big Apple zurück. So, er schreibt, hey Felix, irgendwas stimmt mit eurem Podcast nicht. Der ist nämlich komischerweise über vier Stunden lang und alles wiederholt sich. Ich schreibe mal rein. Moment, ich sehe den gar nicht. Um welchen geht's? Bian Kojrawirat, Big Apple Tech. Er schreibt, hey Felix, irgendwas stimmt mit eurem Podcast nicht. Der ist nämlich komischerweise über vier Stunden lang und wiederholt sich. Ich glaub, er meint uns. Ach man, da musst du auch mal lachen jetzt. Ich seh ihn leider nicht. Da bist du gefragt, als mein Co-Moderator muss lachen. Aber hast du jetzt viel übersprungen oder was? Ja, sehr viel übersprungen. Ja, bitte überspringe nicht so viel, sonst kommen wir komplett durcheinander. Entschuldige, um jetzt hier meine gewisse Schärfe reinzubringen. Ich merke gerade, dass du schon durcheinander kommst. Okay, also was schreibst du? Ich fange mal an mit dem Ha-ha-ha. Ja, sch ha ha ha ha, trauriger Smiley. Das ist die eine Sache. Das ist die eine Sache. Regieanweisung, zieht Weste aus? Nein, nein, nein, nein, bin zieht nichts aus. Ich sollte dir als dein Freund, Komoderator und Anwalt sagen, dass man bitte hör auf, das Wort ausziehen zu gebrauchen. Bruder, von mir aus zieht Weste an. Nein, da steckt mehr dahinter. Also er hört vier Stunden lang einen Podcast und alles wiederholt sich. Das ist ja eine Sache. Wenn du auf Wiederholung... Wenn du auf iTunes bei Informationen... Wenn du auf Wiederholung und... Eönigkeit stehst, try the Podcast UFO auf. Dann Finger weg von unserem Podcast. Dann Finger weg von dem Podcast UFO. Und auch immer von das Podcast UFO. Wir werden nicht dekliniert. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Von das Podcast-Ufo. Okay, wir haben hier noch einen perfekten, der passt perfekt. Also Part of Life schreibt, sehr viele gute Podcasts und so wenig Zeit. Man müsste beruflich, in Klammern, was mit Podcast hören machen. Ideal. Sehr gut, ideal. Schreibt zurück. Ha ha ha. Lacher ist gut. Schreib in Klammern, Lachen, schreib in Lachen, oh ho ho, schreib in Lachen, als Regieanweisung Lachen, ich schreib Sternchen Lachen, Lacht leise, Lacht leise, Lacht leise, zieht Weste aus, nein, nein, an, bitte Flore, ich ne auch damit. Nee, warte. Also, lacht leise,
ja, das kenne ich.
Punkt.
Vielleicht, vielleicht,
das ist eine gute,
also, vielleicht löst dein
Leiden unser Podcast,
so nach dem Sinne, in dem Sinne, dass
er dann vielleicht
das Interesse am Podcast zu haben verliert.
Genau, vielleicht
löscht, nee, vielleicht
Vielen Dank. So nach dem Sinne, in dem Sinne, dass er dann vielleicht das Interesse am Podcast zu hören verliert. Genau, vielleicht löscht, nee, vielleicht vergeht ihr nach unserem Podcast die Lust. Vielleicht vergeht ihr nach dem Podcast-Ufo die Lust. Nach das Podcast-Ufo. Genau, vielleicht vergeht ihr nach das Podcast-Ufo die Lust. Okay, das läuft doch gut. Sehr gut. Das läuft wirklich gut. Nein, ich habe es in meinem eigenen, nein, Idiot. Nein, ich trottel, ey. Dumm kann man sein eigentlich. Nicht nur, dass du kontinuierlich jeden Fehler mitnimmst, den du machen kannst, nein, du machst ihn nur noch zweimal. Hey, herzlich willkommen zum Fehlermachen mit Florian Tien Will. Florian Tien Will entdeckt das Internet. Oh, ein sprechender Elch über eine Kontonummer, das finde ich fair. Habe ich jetzt überhaupt nicht verstanden, aber sprechender Elch, die ist lustig. Also, fuck it. Wir machen mal was, was gar nicht passt. Ich bin heute in Geberlaune, Neues aus der alten Hoffnungsschimmerei. So, das verstehe ich jetzt auch nicht, wie das in diese Suche kommen kann. Ich habe Podcast eingegeben als Suche und es kommt ein Tweet, wo kein Wort vom Podcast entsteht. Kann man eigentlich hier auch filtern nach Leuten, die viele Follower haben? Weil wir müssen ja eigentlich nach Leuten suchen, die viele Follower haben. Users, Annie.
Du meinst, damit die das nochmal verbreiten, als Multiplikatoren.
Aber da musst du halt Glück haben. Da musst du halt
Multiplikatoren finden, die auch so Early Adopters
sind. Ich werfe jetzt einfach
wild mit Fachbegriffen um mich. Und Digital
Natives und so, ja, bestimmt schon. Und als Early
Adopters dann spreaden.
Die spreaden dann den Spirit
des Podcast-Ufos.
Hör doch wacker mal rein, was schreibst du denn eigentlich von Scheiss?
Was?
Ich fühle mich jetzt hart getroffen.
Sagt der, der Zeitwestern, aber noch falsch schreibt.
Wirklich? Was habe ich geschrieben?
Zeitwestern.
Was ist das denn? Echt? Hör doch, wacke mal rein, macht doch noch Sinn. Ich bin gerade völlig... Ach scheiße. Ach scheiße. Man darf nicht lachen, glaube ich, wenn man krank ist. So, bei WDR 5 werden Podcasts eingestellt. So teuer können die ja nicht sein. Wie billig Podcasts sind, kann man sehen. Wir schreiben erstmal so auch wütend. Wir machen erstmal in Regieanweisungen wütend. Aber schreib Regieanweisungen aus. Regieanweisung, Doppelpunkt, wütend. Und ich mache ja kontinuierlich Caps Lock. Auch bei Regieanweisung. Regieanweisung! Was schreibe ich? Soll ich Regieanweisung schreiben? Ja, schreib Regieanweisung aus. Regieanweisung, Doppelpunkt, wütend, Ausrufezeichen. Auch zwischen den Zeilen braucht man einfach eine gewisse Emotionalität. Ausrufezeichen, Regieanweisung, wütend, Alter, wir sind solche Freaks und es wird niemals ankommen. Ja, der Meinung ist das Podcast-Ufo auch, check it out now, check it out, so ein bisschen was Englisches reinbringen, so ein bisschen was Innovatives, check it out now. Oh, guck mal, ich habe jemanden gefunden, eine andere Show, Katrin und Katrin, at Frauenbusiness, der hat geschrieben, jetzt gibt es unsere Podcastshow auch auf Video, zum Beispiel von ganz unten ganz rauf, mit Daniela Ben Said, lohnt sich? Okay, Antwort darauf. Also. Ich finde, Frauen sind super. Es klingt ein bisschen feministisch, was sie machen. Nee, erst mal in Anführungszeichen, also als Regieanweisung erst mal Platons Höhengleichnis, damit man erst mal weiß, wo sich das, was jetzt gesagt wird, abspielt. Damit man weiß, wie man den Tweet einordnen soll. Genau, so ein Betreff zu Platons Höhengleichnis. Hallo Katrin. Hallo Katrin. Liebe Katrin. Mit Freude haben wir deinen Kommentar gelesen. Mit vielen Freunden haben wir euren Kommentar überflogen. Bei Tweets, die nur hundertvielig Zeichen lang sind, von überfliegen zu sprechen, ist auch echt gut. Es ist so ein Mittelfinger. Ich glaube nicht, dass es gut ist, was wir gerade machen. Also ganz kurz, ich habe jetzt nicht mehr viele Zeichen, ich habe nur noch 25 Zeichen übrig. Liebe Katrin, mit vielen Freunden haben wir euren Kommentar überflogen. Das Podcast-Ufo. Mit freundlichen Grüßen, das Podcast-Ufo. Lohnt sich. Das Podcast. Kann es sein, dass man irgendwann auch, also ich glaube, erstens werden wir von Leuten jetzt angefangen zu, also Leute werden anfangen uns zu sperren, glaube ich, ernstens. Dann glaube ich, durch meinen Anfall von Caps Lock, glaube ich, dass Twitter uns eine Verwarnung gibt. Ich würde noch ganz gerne einen, ich habe noch eine Idee, ich würde gerne jemanden haben, der viele Follower hat. Da, René Loch, sehr guter Name, schreibt, schon unseren neuen Podcast gehört, wir blicken noch einmal eine knappe Stunde auf die-Nacht zurück. Okay, und jetzt mach ... Wow, seid ihr up to date. Okay, und jetzt mach Spitze Klammer auf, eins von vierzehn, Spitze Klammer zu. Als wäre das jetzt ein vierzehnteiliger Tweet. Aber es ist nur einer. Es ist nur einer. Oh Gott. Eins von vierzehn, ja. Okay, und dann natürlich wieder eine Regieanweisung, trägt Batman-Maske. Oder trägt eine andere, warte, was kann das für eine Maske? Cat Wonder Woman. Trägt Goofy, trägt Goofy-Maske. Goofy-Kostüm, Bananenkostüm, trägt Bananenkostüm. Trägt Pfirsichkostüm. Trägt Pfirsichkostüm.
Oben ohne.
Uiuiui.
Nein, nein, nein.
Und jetzt, im Namen der Wissenschaft, bitte, bitte, bitte hör unseren Podcast.
Bitte, bitte, bitte.
Ich betone jetzt auch Dinge, ich betone Dinge, die ich die großschreibe.
Bitte, bitte, bitte höre unseren Podcast. Höre unseren Podcast. Das war die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, bitte, bitte, höre unseren. Höre unseren Podcast. Höre unseren Podcast. Das Podcast-Ufo. Sag danke. Das macht echt Spaß. Ich würde sagen, wir hauen noch einen raus. Okay, Felix Schaumburg hat stolze 2200 Follower und er schreibt, man sollte einen Post-Keynote-Podcast machen, Smiley, das hält dazu an, in Anführungszeichen, am Ball
zu bleiben. So.
Also so, vor allem nimmst du immer diese ganzen
Mansions noch mit?
Also wenn der jetzt an, naja, ist zu kompliziert.
Okay, an Felix Schaumburg.
Liebe Grüße hier, du wirst ja wahrscheinlich
den Podcast hören, nach dieser
fantastischen Marketing-Kampagne.
Wir haben schon die erste Antwort bekommen. Oh, wir haben schon zwei Antworten bekommen. Oh Gott, jetzt geht's los. Ha, ha, ha, das ist ja eine Sache, wenn du auf Wiederholung und Einfälligkeit stehst, dann Finger weg von das Podcast-Ufo. Jemand schreibt, schweig du Banause. Wir müssen jetzt schlagfertigen, schweig du Banause. Das ist auf diese Art von weirdem Scheiss, was wir geschrieben haben, noch eine relativ gute Antwort eigentlich. Ja, vor allem, ich find's lame. Nee, da müssen wir uns drauf eingehen. Da gehen wir noch mal drauf ein. Ich schreibe jetzt schweig du großgeschrieben, du Banause. Nein, erst mal Regieanweisung. Zieht sein Banausenkostüm aus. Nein. Oder an. Zieht Banausenkostüm aus. Jetzt hör mal zu, du beschissener Eisvogel. Du beschissener Pfirsich. Das ist zu albern. Beschissener Pfirsich ist zu albern. Beschissen. Das lasse ich nämlich nicht von jemandem sagen, der Eisvogel vorgeschlagen hat. Du beschissener Haudegen. Was sagt man nicht mehr? Du beschissener Grenzgänger. Du beschissener Teufelskerl. Du bist ein Teufelskerl, ja. Du bist ein Teufelskerl. Okay, in Anführungszeichen, äh, Regieanweisung, räuspert sich,. Räuspert sich bedeutungsschwanger.
Räuspert sich und geht ganz nah ans Mikrofon ran.
Wie viele Zeichen haben wir noch?
Es wird auf jeden Fall eine Herausforderung.
Geht ganz nah ans Mikrofon.
Wie viele Zeichen haben wir noch?
Vier.
Drei.
Okay, UFO. Okay. Ja, wenn man nur drei Buchstaben macht. Was soll man machen? Was soll man machen? Wir haben noch eine andere Antwort bekommen. Da läuft einfach Form. Podcast, was mega geil hast du geschrieben? Wir haben geschrieben, knallt Tür zu. Wir suchen noch jemanden, der unseren Podcast gut findet. Hättest du Interesse? Schick mir die Links. Wenn ich toll finde, werde ich zurückfolgen. Erstmal glaube ich, er ist kein Deutscher, er schreibt auch wirklich nicht gut. Dann, er kriegt aber einen Link von uns, aber den falschen. Okay, ich schicke den nicht. Nee, er kriegt schon einen richtigen. Ich meine, das ist ja schon ein bisschen der Sinn der Sache. Ganz kurz, ich schreibe gerade noch an Felix Schaumburg, der die am Ball bleiben, also, in Spitzenklammern Partnerbörse oder erstes Date. Szenario beim Pizzabäcker. Okay, das klingt auch gut. Beim Pizzabäcker. Beim Pizzabäcker, groß geschrieben. Oder schreibt, Eros Armazotti läuft im Hintergrund. Ist dir mal aufgefallen, das ist übrigens auch für mein Stand-Up-Programm, so fange ich an. Hey Leute, ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass bei jedem Pizzabäcker im Hintergrund Eros Ramazzotti läuft? Er wird nicht gut ankommen, aber es ist okay. Ja, aber was jetzt noch fehlt, ist der Witz tatsächlich. Nee, nee. Das ist jetzt, da hatten wir noch nicht drüber gesprochen. Der Witz isthm, keine Komm. Aber da werden sich die Deutschen mal gewöhnen müssen.
Also, beim Pizzabäcker Eros Ramazot läuft im Hintergrund.
Hör mal, das piekst jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen.
Nein, nein, nein, du verfällst wieder deinen alten Zwingen.
Es gibt noch genug sexy Fische im Meer.
Auf jeden Topf passt ein Deckel. Deiner ist vielleicht das Podcast-Ufo.
Okay. Auf jeden Topf passt ein Deckel. Passt ein Dackel. Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Hey, Florian. Deiner, okay,, wuff wuff, Podcast-Ufo. Okay, jetzt wird es mir tatsächlich auch unangenehm. Wir sollten aufhören. Ja, also, das war unsere neue Rubrik, vielleicht hat es euch ja gefallen, unsere neue Rubrik. Ja, die Rubrik Online-Marketing. Florentine-Schwiffmann, twittern zurück. Also, wenn ihr angetwittert werden wollt das nächste Mal, wir nehmen immer Dienstagabend auf. Wenn ihr auch mit dabei sein wollt und live mit twittern wollt, dann überlegt euch eine Möglichkeit, wie ihr das machen könnt. Und twittert uns diese Möglichkeit, dann kommt ihr vielleicht auch in die nächste Sendung. Und ansonsten vielen Dank, Stefan Titz. Vielen Dank, Florentin Bild. Vielen Dank für die tollen Themen, die du mitgebracht hast. Gerne geschehen, nächste Woche. Was ich ganz kurz festhalten möchte, wir haben zu dem jetzigen Zeitpunkt 81 Follower auf Twitter. Das heißt, wenn die Folge raus ist, könnt ihr mal nachgucken, wie viel uns die Marketingkampagne tatsächlich gebracht hat. Und, falls ihr noch nicht folgt, könnt ihr uns natürlich folgen, add das Podcast UFO oder auf iTunes könnt ihr uns abonnieren, Rezensionen verteilen. Also eine Bewertung wäre da echt mal ganz schön.
Da hätten wir noch schöne neue Bewertungen.
Auf Facebook kann man natürlich auch immer so gut seine Meinung sagen.
Ansonsten, ja, ich glaube, ich höre jetzt schon die Musik reinkommen.
Nein, noch nicht ganz.
Ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch eine schöne Woche.
Genießt das Wochenende.
Geht mal raus. Geht vor allem mal mal raus, erledet mein Abenteuer.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn ihr unseren Podcast hört, dann ist sozial bei euch was im Argen, geht mal raus vielleicht und überlegt euch mal vielleicht, ob das alles so Sinn macht noch.
Wir sind auf jeden Fall nächste Woche wieder hier, selbe Zeit, gleiche Stelle und bis dahin wünsche ich und Florentin euch eine schöne Woche. Bleibt das Podcast mit.